bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rtl france d'abord pourquoi la
question des réfugiés elle est
primordiale tout savoir que la syrie à
22 millions d'habitants où avait 21 ans
habitant il y aura plus de presque 6
millions qui sont dehors
il ya environ 5 millions qui sont
réfugiés qui sont déplacés en dehors de
leur maison donc le problème de la syrie
et matin un problème pour s'il était
démographique
certes il ya des gens dans le
gouvernement ou à côté de gouvernement
qui disent il vaut peut-être mieux avoir
des millions d'habitants loyaux que 20
millions qui sont à montils voyous mais
il n'empêche que sur le plan ce plan
moral et sur le plan psychique réessayer
de réunir de rassembler ou de récupérer
une bonne pâte et ses habitants est
quand même très important pour la sir et
surtout quand on envisage la fin des
combats la fin de la guerre et la phase
de reconstruction qui devraient un jour
l'autre s'amorcer c'est un peu difficile
pour les réfugiés syriens de rené en
syrie parce que ils craignent d'abord
pour les jeunes est embarqué dans le
service militaire
ils sont soumis à quelques chantage
extorsions du dual à la corruption
ils savent jamais s'ils leur leurs
opinions ou leurs agissements antérieurs
leur sera reproché il dit se savent
surveillés
ceux qui sont entrés ne sont pas de
véritables bons ambassadeurs pour le
retour de ceux qui ne sont pas encore
rentrés mais en tout cas il est clair
que c'est a besoin vital pour la série
de récupérer ses enfants
alors combien oui oui justement sur le
nombre pardonnez ma choisi interrompue
sur le nombre de réfugiés 5 millions et
demi selon l'onu est ce que ça se
confond ces chiffres sont conformes à
l'arrêter et comment rendre possible
retour de ces réfugiés chez eux dans
quelles conditions
la première condition c'est de l'est de
les rassurer
c'est de leur dire oh vous attend que
personne ne viendra
chercher des poux dans la tête vous
serez pas recruter d'or dans l'armée on
vous jette rapport en prison et on vous
fera pas les payer votre absence qui est
scandaleuse parce que quand le pays
étant en état de difficultés il faut que
tous ses citoyens participent à 100 à sa
défense c'est ça que les réfugiés
syriens craignent ils reprochent à
l'actuel gouvernement en tout - ou
fonctionnaires du gouvernement qui n'a
juste pas de façon très astucieuse pour
les rassurer
et puis il ya aussi le fait que que les
que la turquie n'a pas très envie en
définitive que ces réfugiés syriens parc
c'est vrai qui pourra occulter il ya
deux ans est pire c'est quand même
énorme
ils vivent aux biens les populations y
travaillent
certes ils sont exploités il n'y a pas
de doute mais il n'empêche que la
turquie préférant conserver un certain
nombre pour pouvoir peser non seulement
sur la syrie mais que vous savez sur
nous aussi
l'union européenne et puis en plus vous
savez la turquie utilise une partie de
ces réfugiés sur son sol pour les
envoyer comme mercenaire soir débit soit
en azerbaïdjan en verlan parler à votre
votre émission l'a donc la turquie et ne
va pas dans le même sens que le
gouvernement syrien pour renvoyer en
syrie les réfugiés syriens sur son sol
on ne compte pas
5 million et demi de réfugiés c'est
conforme à la réalité selon vous tout à
fait tout à fait et on ne pas pas des
papas de déplacés il ya environ 2,7
millions en turquie 1,1 million ou au
liban 658 à peu près un jour d'année ne
parle pas de tous ceux qui sont répartis
de partout et d'égypte ou en france en
france on en compte entre 5000 et 10000
est ce que tous ont envie de rentrer
c'est pas sûr mais même si la moitié de
ces 5 millions rend progressivement
qu'est ce fait les l'hérault du retour
pour les autres ça risque de prendre
beaucoup de temps
alors il ya une conférence donc est
prévue dans 2 jours sous la houlette de
damas avec tous les acteurs de la région
que peut-il en ressortir une conférence
c'est bien joli mais c'est pas inutile
mais ce qui est beaucoup plus utile
c'est que peut-être le gouvernement
syrien envoie des émissaires dans des
endroits où sont les réfugiés 2 et
s'adresse aux patrons enfin gros leader
aux dirigeants de se réfugier dans les
pays où ils sont plus structurés et
qu'ailleurs et les rassure et mettre en
exergue le fait que les réfugiés qui
rentrent sont bien traités et ça ça
servira de de poudre de de lancement
pour les autres une conférence
oui pourquoi pas mais pour moi c'est
beaucoup plus sur les réfugiés eux-mêmes
que les le gouvernement syrien devrait
agir
merci beaucoup à vous dédiez destremau
je rappelle que vous êtes ancien
ambassadeur auteur de romans de la série
ce